hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the groundwork
for the metaphysics of morals Kant
provides you with several different
formulations of his main moral principle
a categorical imperative this is the
first formulation act only on that Maxim
through which you can at the same time
will that should be a universal law and
he tells me about it in general he also
gives you four specific examples about
how this would apply in terms of strict
duties to others meritorious or wide
duties to others strict duties to the
self and then meritorious duties to the
self remember the difference between
strict and meritorious is strict duties
or duties that in order to be a moral
person you have to do you have to comply
with so to fail to do a strict duty to
fail to choose a strict duty is worthy
of blame a meritorious Duty is not
incumbent upon one with the same amount
of strength or rigor so if you didn't do
it it wouldn't be a good thing but
you're not morally bad for not doing
you're just not morally good it would be
better for you to do it than not to do
it now kind of gives you a number of
examples of his own but I think that if
we're going to think about Kant's ethics
it's often helpful to come up with their
own examples and then see how these
would apply and Kant's first formulation
of the categorical imperative is really
it for a lot of these examples not as
easy to apply as you'd like it to be
you'll find that the second formulation
that has to do with with treating people
or rather treating humanity as an end
rather than just a means alone actually
clarifies a lot of these but let's try
to work our way through these I've put
together sort of a list of different
ones that we can look at let's try to
work our way through them and see just
how far we can get with them and that
will show us to some extent how
applicable this this general principle
which Kant thinks is the sort of you
know touchstone or from morality how
applicable that really is so one of the
big moral issues that you can think
about it has to do with killing killing
another human being
now Kant talked about whether it's
morally permissible to kill oneself and
he concluded that you have a strict duty
to yourself to maintain your own life so
suicide is out of the question
what about killing another person and
there we would want to look at the maxim
that's involved you know maybe there's a
difference between callously going up to
another person and saying I'd like to
see you know what happens when I kill
this person you know how do they say
curiosity or soci sociopathy right yeah
killing somebody see for material gain
or killing somebody motivated by revenge
or let's say killing somebody in order
to protect other innocent people from
being killed by that person or killing
somebody in a case of clear self-defense
these don't all necessarily involve the
same man
it is the same action in a certain
extent a person is being killed or it's
being proposed that I should kill this
person and the person who's about to do
that is asking themselves would it be
moral for me to do so would it be right
for me to do so so let's take some
really easy cases let's start with you
know I have nothing against this
particular person I don't even know who
they are
there's actually this this case that's
brought up in a article called the case
of the obliging strangers so I go up to
somebody on the street and I say hey
I've got an experiment I'd like you to
help me out with it would you come along
with me and the obliging stranger says
y-yes of course anything for Sciences
sake and I bring them into my my house
and I hit them on the head with a hammer
and knock them out and then I put them
into an oven and turn the oven on and
they they died as a result now the the
writer of that William gasps says any
moral theory that you know is worth
anything and better tell you that that's
wrong so the question is and gas points
us out well what's wrong with it
precisely so what current would say in a
case like that is in terms of the
categorical imperative you can ask
what's the maxim here and it would be
something along the lines of anytime
that I decide I would like to kill
somebody I will kill that person even if
I have no reason to do so
and now can we can we make that into a
universal law of nature can we say
everybody shall do that hunt would
probably have no trouble saying if you
think that through that can't possibly
work why well you could you could look
at in a couple different ways one of the
ways I think that would be most
promising would be to say what are you
doing in a case like that what does the
world like that look like it becomes
totally capricious people are killing
each other
for no reason whatsoever they are taking
they're taking away one of the most you
know valuable things the very capacity
to actually do anything to feel anything
to to choose anything from other people
they're making that into a universal
condition well if that's the case then
humanity just sort of disappears because
sooner or later everybody wants to kill
somebody they suppose that makes us a
little consequentialist though is there
anything inherently contradictory self
contradictory in imagining a situation
like that where anybody at any time
for no reason whatsoever may choose and
once they start to do choose that they
actually do they follow through on it
and they kill other people is there any
sort of inherent contradiction in that I
think there is if you if you actually
start thinking it through what about
some other cases that are a little bit
stickier we might say what about killing
somebody for hire in a way the maximum
for that is a lot easier to wrap your
head around any time that it shall be
useful to me or I will gain something
out of it
I will kill another person so it could
be you know becoming a contract killer
it could be benefiting from somebody's
death because they are no longer in your
your job that you want to have it could
be that they're a financial rival to you
it could be that you're gonna inherit
their wealth so the general principle is
anytime that I have some sort of gain
from it I will I will kill another
person now imagine again a world in
which this is the rule for everybody
that's not just a rule like well you
should do this it's a rule that
everybody does do that what would that
will be like well it wouldn't be a world
that that's got a high population for
one thing because theoretically I mean
if you think it through
everybody could kill everybody to get
something out of them if only to take
what they've got yeah
then you know think about the point of
having things the point of financial
gain financial gain is ultimately not
you know valuable in itself it's
valuable insofar as it leads to the
amenities of life or to a better life or
something like that so life would be in
a sense cancelling out life in the
process so you would have a
contradiction there at least for my
conscience perspective right again we're
sticking with cot here this isn't
necessarily what I think this is the way
a conscient would have to see it
what about self defense what about cases
where somebody kills another person in
order to either defend themselves or to
defend other innocent people now can
actually does discuss this not in this
work but in in the metaphysical elements
of justice and he says you can't
actually legitimately kill somebody in
self-defense who hasn't done anything to
you but now let's imagine a group an
aggressor somebody has already knocked
you down they're standing over you and
they say to you I'm gonna kill you you
happen to have a sharpened screwdriver
this is a regular screwdriver they're
sharp enough in your in your tool belt
and you can jam it up into them and you
actually know that if you hit them you
know on the right place and you screw
around you're probably gonna kill them
is it okay for you to do that is it the
right thing to do well oh yeah let's
think about what the Matteson would be
in a case like that in order to protect
my own life when there is no other
alternative because of the actions of an
aggressor who has imposed this upon me I
will take the life of the aggressor okay
that's a fairly decent way of putting it
can we make that into a universal law
could you have a world in which that was
in fact the way things
work I don't see any problem cognizing
or imagining that imagine a world in
which any time that somebody else will
call them X goes so far as to impose on
Y the situation either kill or be killed
and you can't escape from that person Y
kills person X well you could easily
have a case where nobody does that
there's no inherent contradiction
involved in thinking of a world like
that
uh could you will a world like that I
don't think there'd actually even be a
problem yeah necessarily willing a world
like that where if an aggressor imposes
upon the I suppose you'd call them the
aggressor the subject of aggression or
the object of aggression a choice a
stark choice kill or be killed
and you know they leave them no third
alternative you know the person talks
about don't don't make me do this they
say but I want to right if they force
that does it make sense to will that in
in cases like that the other person
should kill them I don't see any problem
with with the Willing that from a
Content perspective either it's not as
if you'd be willing world in which you
know your will would in some way be the
contradictory you're actually willing
that justice be done in a certain sense
and if you extend this to protecting
innocent people you might actually need
that protection so long as you don't
choose to become an aggressor there
doesn't seem to be any problem with this
if if you in fact have a motive in your
will and you say I love hurtin people I
love killing people I want a world in
which I get to do that well then that
wouldn't be for you but but we've
already seen that that that's not a
moral perspective right so self-defense
seems like it it would be licit or
allowable from a conscience
perspective if you're dealing with other
people perhaps there's actually a duty
to protect them
other innocence that you can do that in
the face of aggression is there anything
else to be said about this I think
there's two other things that we could
say about this now if you're going to
resist aggression with deadly force
potentially deadly force are there any
limits on that force I think you could
say there's two ways of looking at this
again from a conscient perspective where
the categorical imperative could apply
and it could make sense the limited one
would be the threshold that an aggressor
or a potential aggressor or possible
aggressor has to cross before you
actually trigger some sort of response I
don't think that you could justify
something like a preemptive strike
against somebody where it where it's
kind of iffy from a Content perspective
because again what would a world be like
where we all did that
oh you're you might be coming after me
so I'm gonna I'm gonna get you that's
not going to that's not going to satisfy
this requirement you're not going to be
able to make that into a coherent world
picture as a matter of fact what does
that lead to something very much like
Hobbes imaginary war of all against all
state of nature in which life is nasty
brutish and short as he puts it and and
becomes almost inconceivable when you
when you push it far enough that's one
thing what about this now let's say you
have the capacity to use what what is
you know likely going to be deadly force
but could be used in a non deadly way
for instance do you shoot to kill
center of mass or right in the head or
do you try to incapacitate an opponent
now of course this assumes that you
actually have that that sort of
possibility well let's say you do have
that possibility do you have a duty then
to the aggressor not to kill them but
rather to incapacitate or to render them
unable to to follow through on their
intent to to kill you or harm you I
think if you're going to make a case for
that the best that you could get would
be a meritorious duty so a police
officer for example faced with a
dangerous criminal who's already you
know exhibited the the intent to use
deadly force against innocence for the
police's protecting and against the
police officer would can't say they have
a moral obligation of strict duty to
shoot to incapacitate I don't think so
do they have meritorious duty to try to
keep that person from dying by shooting
them say in the leg and incapacitate
them I think God would be willing to say
they have a meritorious duty to do that
and we could go through the categorical
imperative but I want to keep this
rolling along don't ready to do that
what about duty to yourself do you have
a duty to yourself to protect yourself
well do you have a strict duty to
yourself to preserve your own life in
the face of another's aggression if that
means that you have to take their their
life let's see again can we universalize
that anytime that somebody will begin to
threaten me with deadly force I will use
deadly force against them can that be
made into a universal law can we imagine
a world in which that takes place yes we
can't in fact imagine a world in which
that takes place can I will that that be
the case we examined that before I don't
see myself maybe somebody else you know
who is more of a conscience that I
what would point this out to me I don't
see any inherent discrepancy or
contradiction or or you know problematic
status of willing that that world either
if we said something like if the Maxima
was something like anytime somebody
seems to threaten me I'll go after him
yeah then we wouldn't want to will that
but if we're if we qualified me say
anytime that somebody is clearly using
deadly force against me
I will use deadly force against them to
try to protect myself I think we can
well that's that that means that we've
got something that actually is a moral
duty you have a maxim that you can act
upon that you can will to be a universal
law in that case let's move on to
something else
let's think about giving fair verdicts
there's a really interesting law in the
the Old Testament in the Torah I think
it might be in Leviticus where it's
actually instructing judges that they
are not to pervert justice and they're
not to pervert it in two different ways
there now to give unfair verdicts to the
rich because the rich bribed them or you
know over why them or they they favor
them for some reason they're also not to
give unfair verdicts to the poor out of
out of pity or sympathy for them because
they I can also skew that in a sense
that's a very conscious way of looking
at it not Material gain or prestige and
not being moved by sympathy either but
sticking to to justice now let's say a
judge actually says to themselves I am
tempted to give an unfair verdict would
it be okay for me to do so so now what
would that of the maxim be well let's
say it's the rich person when a rich
person bribes mirror you know when I
when I derive some financial gain from
it I will
you're an unfair verdict I will
contravene justice now let's say the
maximum is something like when I feel
sympathy for the person who is before me
I will give I will give them an unfair
verdict which favors them over the the
other person imagine a world in which
that becomes the norm and not just the
norm in the sense that this happens most
of the time but this happens in every
single case so every single time that a
judge has some financial motive or is
moved by sympathy they render an unfair
verdict would it make sense to even have
a system of justice in that case what is
the guiding idea of the system of
justice that these two people you know
can't actually decide or whatever two
sides can't actually decide on what
counts is fair so they appeal to a third
person a third party who is supposed to
be impartial and render justice one side
or the other or perhaps you know
splitting it down the middle well if we
said that every time that a person has
something to gain from endures being
moved by by their emotions they should
render an unfair verdict the whole
system of justice would no longer even
make sense it's not just that it would
like collapse empirically rationally it
wouldn't even make it wouldn't even make
sense you'd be undoing it so you
actually have a strict duty to to be
fair when giving verdicts let's talk
about I don't wanna you know I have a
lot of examples here but I want to keep
this fairly short because it is a core
concept video let's talk about insulting
or offending others now do you have a
duty not to insult or offend others this
is a very important one to think about
because there's a lot of ways in which
it's easy especially in the kind of
ladies that we tend to live in now where
people are coming from all different
backgrounds have all different points of
view where it can be quite easy to
offend somebody without even necessarily
meaning to and once you've offended them
and then maybe you have to think about
well sure am I going to continue to do
this this thing that actually offends
them or am I not going to do that am I
going to refrain from it form a line and
this isn't just an issue in
heterogeneous societies even in fairly
homogeneous societies if you you know
look at literature people find ways to
offend each other because we have all
sorts of different roles we occupy
different different spaces we have lots
of ways to misunderstand each other and
we're all you know it's a some degree
about some things sensitive so let's
think about what the maxim could be in a
case like that I'm in a situation I know
that saying a certain thing let's make
it a joke right
I'm tempted to make a joke and yet I
know that joke will probably be
offensive to one of the people in the
room it will cause them some
psychological pain maybe make them feel
less valuable humiliated in comparison
to the other people in the room and it
might actually make the other people you
know they might say yeah it's a great
joke I enjoyed that right is it okay for
me to do that or do I have a duty to to
refrain from that sort of thing what was
the maximum in situations where I can
either offend or not offend another
person I will give them offence that
could be the maximum it could be
something along the lines of whenever it
will give me pleasure and give other
people possibly give other people
pleasure
I will inflict displeasure upon another
person
or perhaps even humiliation on another
person by offending them let's use that
one
so whatever it's pleasant for me and
perhaps for other people I will impose
displeasure and perhaps humiliation on
another person let's say that becomes
the world the norm can you imagine a
world like that and think it through
would there be any inherent
contradictions you know I don't think so
I think you can imagine a world like
that quite coherently you know we're all
like Don Rickles going around singing
each other or something like that would
you will such a world would you if you
really aren't honest with yourself I
know there's some people would be like
yeah sounds great screw everybody else
what it really makes sense to will a
world like that no it wouldn't so I
think you can say that there's actually
a meritorious duty involved here to
others not to offend or to insult them
not to give them offence
now you know could there be any sort of
corresponding duty I'm not going to go
very deep into this but could there be
any other corresponding duty to oneself
or to other people not to take undue
offence not to be too prickly not to be
too easily offended I'm willing to bet
that from a conscience perspective if we
thought this out there there would be
you know I'm reminded very much of this
saying by st. Francis DeSales which
talks about scandal scandal means taking
offence at somebody else's actions or
words or something like that allowing
oneself to be offended literally a
stumbling block a scandal
and Saint Francis says that and those a
very extreme view he says those who
commit scandal commit spiritual murder
but those who allow themselves to be
scandalized too easily or for the wrong
reasons
they actually commit spiritual suicide I
think there's something to that I think
that there's there's some sort of
reciprocal relation between allowing
oneself to be offended too easily and
the people who offend let's move on do
to look at a few others some other
examples fidelity in marriage this is an
interesting one originally when I
thought this through I thought in terms
of like cheating you know like like
committing adultery you know it doesn't
necessarily have to be marriage could be
any sort of committed relationship where
there's an expectation of monogamy but
cheating can cover a lot of different
things and you know we talked about
emotional Affairs actually in the South
you can actually you can sue somebody
for what they call estrangement of
affection if you catch them you know
that one I think you actually do have to
some cheating involved you know the idea
of a strange minute of affection from
the one person who you're supposed to be
affectionate with to another person
because there's some sort of promise
being made there's some sort of
commitment being made there's another
modality of cheating as well what we
call financial infidelity if you have a
household in which people have have
actually merged things this is the way
marriage is you know typically work and
one person is deceiving the other as to
you know where they actually stand where
the fruits of their labors are going
then you can you know running up credit
card bills for example that the other
person doesn't know about this happens
quite frequently you've got financial
infidelity so you could have infidelity
in a lot of different ways let's say we
think in terms of just you know general
I've made a commitment to somebody and
I'm going to break that commitment while
I'm still involved with them
so what would the max of me because it
suits me even though I person is
committed to me in the relationship that
we have formed I will while drawing upon
that relationship deceive them and and
not do what's what's required of me in
that relationship I will transgress that
relationship okay let's make that into a
universal law now everybody does that in
every relationship does that make sense
that's a pretty easy one is there any
point in having relationships that the
entire notion of committed relationship
then just sort of becomes defunct so
that's a pretty good case for you know
this is this first formulation of the
categorical imperative I would say you
have a strict duty if you enter into
some sort of relationship like that and
you know it's got different dimensions
so sexual
in terms of affection or perhaps even
respect of the other person financial
maybe we look at other dimensions as
well you know maybe there's a lot more
to it once you've entered into a
relationship like that Khan would say
you actually have a duty to your your
partner and that person has a duty
towards you as well not to engage in
infidelity to be faithful if we want to
put in more positives if a duty of
fidelity to you we've talked a lot about
duties to others we talked a little bit
about duties to self now let's think
about some examples that have much more
to do with the self here's one that Kant
doesn't consider as such in the
groundwork he asks about you know is it
okay to kill yourself or shorten your
life you know to make your life less
unpleasant and he says no about that
what about providing for yourself
he talks about the need to cultivate
your talents
but what about actually providing for
yourself like think about something
really prosaic what about do you have a
duty to say provide for your retirement
that's a really concrete kind of thing
that we all have to do if we live long
enough worried about or at least concern
ourselves with can we fit that into cons
categorical imperative and make it do
its job and tell us do we actually have
a duty to provide for herself or don't
leave let's say somebody is tempted to
say screw it you know other people will
take care of me or there'll be some sort
of governmental safety net or you know
something will come along and do it so
I'm not going to set any any money aside
for retirement I I could do it you know
my employer has a plan and they'll make
these contributions if I make
contributions but screw it I want to use
the money now to do the sort of things
that I like so what's the maxim there
it's something along the lines of in
order that I enjoy my time now I will
not set aside the resources to take care
of myself to make sure that I'm not a
undue unfair burden upon other people in
the future now imagine a world in which
that is the norm
could you imagine a world in which that
is the norm I think that is imaginable I
think that there's no inherent
contradiction in conceiving of such a
world is there that's worth thinking
about the maxim is that everybody shall
for the short for the the sake of
shorter term enjoyment refrain from
making any sort of provision
or the future that's to come yeah I
think I think there's no one here in
contradiction there would you will such
a world so now imagine a world in which
everybody else does this which means
that you are yourself at some point in
time can you have to either you know say
well they're all just gonna die or you
have to take care of them and think
about it this way you're gonna have to
take care of some other people who said
ah I don't worry about the future I'll
just go on the dole and suck you know
off of everybody else and they'll all
contribute to it you'll have to
contribute to that before they do and
then later on you'll be saying that's
other people there's the risk of course
to it in this world that everybody else
says tough you didn't put any anything
aside screw you we're not gonna take
care of you would it make sense to will
such a world it wouldn't really make
sense the will such a world so even
though you can conceive of a world
fitting that Maxim that wouldn't make
sense that means that there's a
meritorious duty involved a meritorious
duty to take care of yourself to provide
for yourself to to make sure that you
are taken care of that you have the
resources that you need in the future at
least to intended not necessarily to
make it happen I mean you could say well
what if you do what if it's impossible
for you well you know if it's impossible
for you that doesn't mean that you
didn't intend it that just means that it
you know circumstances didn't work out
that way I'm gonna cut off here there's
a lot of other examples that we could
possibly think of for this for this
categorical imperative this formulation
of it but hopefully this has helped you
to understand how a conch in might
approach some of these these other
issues and now you've got a better
handle on how to apply this kind of
tricky formula or way of thinking about
things